thank you all so much happy to be here
have you ever had a really great idea in
the shower have you ever wondered why
you have really great ideas in the
shower it's kind of annoying isn't it
I mean why not have this great idea in
your office or at least somewhere that's
kind of dry somewhere where you're not
trying to open your phone with your wet
fingers swiping over and over again
trying to get it to turn on so you can
take a note what is going on with this
it turns out the shower sets just the
right conditions to activate the part of
your brain that creates breakthroughs
it's a part that we don't give
centerstage to nearly enough this is the
part of your brain responsible for
creativity and 99% of people around the
world have never heard of it so what is
this part of your brain what is this
part that gives us our human genius our
inventiveness our innovation it enabled
Einstein to discover his special theory
of relativity and it enabled Keith
Richards to write the hit song
satisfaction we tend to think of
breakthrough moments as being accidental
lucky moments they're anything but and
thanks to recent narrow science
discoveries we can not only explain
breakthroughs we can help you set the
conditions to induce them so do you want
to know what this part of your brain is
yes you want to know how to gain access
to it we thought you might so without
further ado it's really the story of two
systems and some of you right now might
be thinking to yourselves oh this is
going to be a left-brain right-brain
thing no take that concept and try and
remove it it's very outdated your brain
is a series of overlapping networks and
we're going to
talk about two of them the first one is
the executive network now this one for
those of you who are overachievers
you're probably very familiar with it
it's very fastidious it's very punctual
it's always got a goal its oriented
towards that goal its task focused it's
making a list it's checking it twice
it's picking people up at the airport
this is the part of you that you put on
a resume the second network is called
the default Network and it's called that
because when you're not on task you
default to it it's made up of about ten
brain region everything from sensory
information to metacognition future
prediction to memory error prediction to
empathy we like to call it the genius
lounge it's nonlinear and it's the seat
of all your genius ideas this you do not
put on your resume allow me to give you
an example imagine this resume 2014 to
2016 senior director of staring off into
space randomly every 20 minutes or so
and lead of random and meandering
walking in the middle of the day 2017 to
present got promoted SVP of imagining
the world without trees kind of a
ridiculous thing to put on your resume
the thing of it is is it shows our
biases it shows the level of our biases
that we would never put anything like
that on a resume because the science
tells us that it is exactly these sorts
of behaviors we need in order to have
breakthroughs whether it's Dmitri
Mendeleev waking up from a nap and
having the periodic table in his head or
Verner Heisenberg walking home from
dinner with Niels Bohr across the park
and suddenly discovering the uncertainty
principle the stories about this process
are seemingly endless now at this point
some of you might be saying to
yourselves well I'm just not a creative
type I want to promise all of you that
everyone in this room has this system
that we're talking about you have the
same exact system in your brain as
Einstein
to say I'm not a creative person is
equivalent to sitting on a couch for two
straight years basically not moving and
your friend comes over and bets you you
can't do five push-ups and when you
can't do even one you roll on your back
you give a big sigh and you go well I
guess I'm just a couch potato I think
I'm going to double down on this couch
sitting thing you know that's not true
you know you have muscles
they've just atrophied when you say I'm
not a creative person it's the same
thing your brain has the muscles you're
just accepting the fact that you're a
neuro couch potato what you need to do
is practice breakthrough thinking is not
a theory it's something that you do and
so you have to get your brain in shape
for it and that means practicing so what
is it that you have to practice three
main things these are the three keys to
breakthrough thinking neuroplasticity
associative thinking and mode switching
we use these with individuals we use
them with teams we use them with entire
organizations so let's start with
neuroplasticity Erik Weihenmayer has
climbed the 7 tallest mountains on all
seven continents now this means he has
climbed the sixteen thousand foot
mountain Vinson in Antarctica personally
I don't know why you would do all seven
mountains on seven continents but he did
it's impressive nonetheless what's even
more impressive is that he is blind and
so you might ask yourself how did he
manage to do this and the answer is he
used a mechanism called a brain port the
brain port is a camera with a little
relay that sits on the tongue the camera
converts visual data into electrical
impulses just like your eye does but
instead of sending it up the optic nerve
into the brain it sends it through the
tongue into the brain now Lana Meyers
brain was not built to interpret visual
data through his tongue but his brain we
wired itself to be able to do that the
most important thing you have to
understand about neuroplasticity is that
your brain is
physical structure your brain is
rewiring itself every second of every
day for you to have a new idea you have
to literally build new neural
connections between your neurons
physical structures when you have a
breakthrough idea there is a physical
corollary in your brain you can
literally look and see the new neural
loop that has been created to create
this breakthrough now the exercises I'm
going to share with you right now are
not necessarily going to create
breakthroughs for you but what they are
going to do is build up your muscle it's
kind of like doing cardio and strength
training if you're an athlete so here's
the first one and this one we tend to do
with teams a lot before getting to a
larger question with them it sort of
pops their brains open so I want you all
to close your eyes and if you're
listening to this on a podcast and
driving right now please don't close
your eyes and don't look at your phone
but for the rest of you please close
your eyes and I want you to imagine this
thought experiment what would our world
look like if gravity stopped working at
10 p.m. and then started working again
at 7 a.m. how has our culture evolved if
that is the situation are there Nets
over everyone's homes are the people who
own the next the richest people on the
planet do people put their beds on the
ceilings and then put mats on the floor
in case they fall and oversleep how do
teenagers decide to rebel and get in
trouble do they grab a bottle of alcohol
and cut a hole in the net and just float
off somewhere depending on who you ask
you get different answers designers
start designing whole houses to be
careful for this artists start depicting
all the beautiful art that could be
created in zero-g
okay you can open your eyes one of the
things to look for is how was that
experience for you was it exhilarating
was it exhausting was it frightening was
it a lot of fun how comfortable are you
in engaging in these wide-open things
and when you came upon an idea you'd
never come upon before you had to build
the structure in your brain to actually
visualize it that's plasticity
here's another one you can play with at
home
turn on a foreign movie with no
subtitles for 20 minutes and trying to
figure out what's going on notice what
you pay attention to you might start
paying attention to the tone of voice or
the way the camera is angled or what
people are doing with their faces or
their bodies you start taking in
completely different information which
is forcing you to build completely
different connections again it might
seem like very far afield from having a
breakthrough but it's building the
muscle towards those breakthroughs
that's the important part
when it comes to plasticity it works
both ways as well it's not just about
building new connections we also have to
prune away old useless connection in
order to make space so your brain has a
delete button we have an article about
this on our website you can literally
set your brain to forget things so that
you create more space so you can have
more and new ideas it's working on both
sides that's just a very quick run
through how neuroplasticity plays into
this the next tool is associative
thinking now associative thinking is
kind of the the magic of the brain
because it's taking different ideas that
you may not think are connected and
bringing them together and finding the
pattern finding the similarity between
them that can allow you to have a
breakthrough Steve Jobs once said
creativity is just putting things
together and in many ways your default
network is just putting things together
so Samuel O'Reilly was walking down the
street in New York in the early 1900s
and looked in the window and saw one of
Thomas Edison's least successful
inventions the electric pen I'm guessing
most of you had no idea that Thomas
Edison created an electric pen that's
how successful it was
but O'Reilly saw something in it and he
took it home and he started playing with
it and he created the world's first
modern tattooing machine he was a tattoo
artist he saw something in it it didn't
have to be made out of the blue he could
associate to something brand new and
shift the way he responded to it's just
the way he reacted to it I want to show
you this so
this is a write-up of the opening of the
plot of Disney's Pocahontas this is from
a guy Matt Dayton in online and what's
interesting is if you take the date and
you take the names in the place and you
change them with all of those things
from the movie Avatar
you basically find out it's the same
exact movie they are literally telling
the same exact story and you can find
this a lot all throughout literature all
the games you can play is people layer
things on top of each other so here's a
fun one for you to do at home when you
have time watch The Matrix trilogy after
you watch that trilogy watch the lego
movie and tell me what you find and you
can play this game with all kinds of
movies you can play this game with all
kinds of books the patterns start
playing over and over again
it's kind of fascinating and fun so the
question becomes where's the rubber
meets the road on this stuff why are we
even bothering with it so Bill O'Connor
from Autodesk is the head of the Human
Genome Project and they've come up with
seven essential innovation questions
which at first you're like are you
kidding me but you actually go through
it and you find out that it's actually a
very effective guide to lead you through
any kind of solution you're looking for
and looking at it from multiple angles
multiple directions helping you
associate it in different ways so the
seven questions are look use move
interconnect alter make and imagine now
those seven each of them breaks down
into six sub questions so it becomes a
very long list that you can popcorn
through and build us some amazing
consulting work using this but what it
does is it creates a concrete frame
around which to engage in a very
ethereal process which is the
breakthrough when I work with special
forces we do it in a slightly different
way and we look at historical situation
and ask ourselves can we learn anything
from what happened
the past to gauge what's going to happen
right now we took a look at the Arab
Spring and we compared it to the
revolutions of 1848 and discovered
amazing similarities that actually
predicted how the Arab Spring was going
to play out and in another time we took
a look at how Germany almost won World
War one because of decentralized
communication and how there were lessons
to be learned about fighting al-qaeda at
the time so looking into the past to
gain a sense of what's going on right
now can have a huge effect on what you
see is possible what you see is a
breakthrough one last story I'll tell
you about this Henry Ford West
Bloomfield hospital needed a new CEO so
they hired gerard van grinnin he had
never worked in a hospital in his life
however he had a lot of experience
creating a very attentive supportive
staff he had a lot of experience being
on call at any hour of the night he had
a lot of experience of getting people
into their rooms quickly and he had a
lot of experience of putting the guests
first he had been an executive with the
ritz-carlton hotels for 25 years West
Bloomfield has become one of the best
hospitals in the world famous for its
breakthroughs and its innovations all
because somebody was able to see the
connection between running a hotel and
running a hospital and how moving from
one to the other could have a positive
effect on the hospital it's being open
to these possibilities that is one of
the key elements to doing this work and
that's why I'm encouraging you to play
have fun with these things find the
patterns where you can go far out of
field Carl Jung's entire opus that he's
passed on to future generations started
when he decided to go into his backyard
and start playing like he did as a child
so the next time you're hanging out with
a little kid clay with them don't watch
them play actually get down at their
level see what they're doing engage with
them it will bring in information you
are not expecting and shift things
completely for you it's an incredibly
powerful
experience so the last skill I want to
talk about is mode switching this is
switching between your executive network
and your default network and I want to
show you an animated video about how
Keith Richards use mode switching to
come up with a hit song Florida 1965 the
Rolling Stones are on their first US
tour but they're not the Rolling Stones
yet they're about as popular as Herman's
Hermits what their need of is a
breakthrough hit a number one song and
no one knows it more than Keith Richards
one night in his motel room Richards was
trying to write that song so what's
going on inside his brain he's
attempting to have this breakthrough
this is the executive of Keith Richards
is brain it's focused on tasks and has a
goal write a hit song there's just one
problem it's not very good at
breakthroughs by itself see the
executive network is great when you need
to make a list to complete a project but
when it comes to having a breakthrough
it needs some help that night Richards
fell asleep and no longer on task is
executive went to talk to another
network that lies deeper in the brain
now what we're about to show you is not
unique to Keith Richards you have the
same exact room in your brain we all do
we just don't access it enough this is
your genius lounge about 10 different
brain regions in here all hanging out
talking there is Mozart Leonardo da
Vinci Mary Curie
I'm Stein welcome to the part of your
brain that's working on stuff when you
don't think you're working on stuff that
night Richards is executive walked in
and said quiet all right everyone we
need a breakthrough hit now go the
executive went and busied itself with
something mindless in this case sleep
but it can be doing the dishes of the
laundry or taking a shower
meanwhile the geniuses started sharing
all kinds of information from art to
music to childhood memories this was the
sum total of Keith Richards's experience
and knowledge and the
combining created his intuition it
created a breakthrough Richards woke up
in the middle of the night and began to
play that was how the Rolling Stones got
their breakthrough hip satisfaction but
it is not just Keith Richards
we all have an executive and a genius
lounge in our brains the key to having
more breakthroughs is learning how to
switch between the two modes can
absolutely choose story and Richards
actually talks about how the next
morning he woke up having no memory what
he had done and he saw the tape recorder
had run all the way out and so he
rewound it was 59 minutes of him snoring
and about 30 seconds of the opening bars
of satisfaction and he said he fell
right back to sleeping you can hear the
guitar pick fall out of his hand and hit
the floor these stories as I said
they're kind of legendary they're
happening all the time and it's about
this ability to kind of step into this
open space where we allow different
random ideas to connect with one another
and then to step back out to switch out
of that mode back to the executive
because we're going to have a bias one
way or the other some people are going
to have a bias for the executive and
they're going to say the executive
network is what gets everything done
it's all about hard work it's about
perspiration it's about discipline
anybody can have a good idea it's all
about the implementation I'm sure you've
heard all of these things at different
times in your life other people are
going to have a bias towards the default
Network it's all about staying loose
giving yourself time being open-minded
just letting things emerge both are
completely true what we need is we need
the openness to allow them both to
happen to switch back and forth now when
we work with individuals one of the
things that we do is work with them to
create be spaces these are the sort of
spaces that happen when you're falling
asleep when you get into the shower we
have a bias against them we feel like if
we're not using our executive network
we're not really working and we feel
like if we're using a default network
somehow we're slacking off somehow this
isn't what we're supposed to be doing
but to actually create time to actually
use our executive network to create a
focus to say this is a goal I want to
fill our brains with a certain amount of
information and then to be able to
switch modes to be able to let go and
just let your brain wander about this is
the key because then when you actually
have an idea it will come back into your
consciousness and now you need the
discipline again now you need to work on
it when it came out of his head and you
have those opening eight bars from Keith
Richards it wasn't done The Rolling
Stones recorded it the next day in
Chicago and they recorded it as kind of
a slow bluesy thing and nobody liked it
it didn't work two days later they were
in LA they had a different producer in a
different studio and the rest of the
band started weighing in and what it
should be and from all of that
back-and-forth
that's when you ended up with the
satisfaction that we all know so the
switching between the giving yourself
the focus but then giving yourself the
leeway to have the idea and then working
hard on the idea this is what makes it
all possible
now we've adapted what we've learned
from the brain for people to use with
their teams for people to use with their
organizations one of the things that we
talked about we have an article about
this is what we call quiet and loud
brainstorming this is a way of bringing
mode switching into a roomful of people
where you simply give everyone a topic
and then it's quiet for the first five
minutes or ten minutes and everybody
writes down their thoughts then you open
it up and it gets loud for however long
a little bit short of five minutes let's
say everybody shares their information
and then you everybody goes quiet again
and writes what they think you keep
bouncing in and out like this through
this brainstorm and it gives everybody a
chance to bring their ideas to the table
it kind of opens it up in a different
way another one that we like to use is
bio mimicking the brain so you've got
this structure you've got all these
different pieces that your brain is
using to create a breakthrough to
connect different ideas and so what we
did is we figured out that if you fill
the space with people who are mavens
they're really on top of what's going on
in the world people who are makers they
love building things people who are deep
serous they're just caught in their
heads and they know all the theory
for then people who are wide generalist
they know a lot about a lot of things
then you get people in there who have a
lot of empathy you get people in there
who have a tremendous amount of
experience all over the place and then
you have people who are kind of like
there they're deep in this in terms of
their memory they've been around the
block before with whatever it is you're
working on they know the history this is
a way to actually mimic what your brain
is doing when you have a breakthrough
both to mimic it outside to bring all of
these disparate pieces together and then
engage them in mode switching which we
can create more of these breakthroughs
the reason we ended up looking at how to
take what the brain is doing and apply
it to people in organizations was
because we kept running into these
issues our clients had they kept getting
told you need to be more collaborative
you need to diversify you need to
decentralize you need to be flatter but
nobody had any idea how to do these
things and so people did things like
have open offices they decided to have
slack channels how's that working out
for everybody right everybody is wearing
headphones they're reserving the
reserving conference spaces so they can
sit alone and they're lobbing bombs on
open flack channels and just creating
all kinds of mayhem because nobody knows
how to do this but our brain has
actually mastered how to handle
complexity how to move through
complexity and find the signal for the
noise and so by using the brain systems
and processes as a guide and mimicking
it to build tools we have enabled people
to start engaging with the complexity of
the world while at the same time being
effective at being collaborative
allowing diverse voices into the room
being more transparent being more
respectful this is where the study of
the brain is paying off in huge
dividends because it is so well evolved
for the world that we live in these are
the three main tools neuroplasticity
associative thinking mode switching but
the question is still there what is it
to have a breakthrough what's it like to
have a breakthrough
well it kind of depends on your own
personal breakthrough style we've
identified for now that doesn't mean
these are the only four but when we
looked around and kind of broke down
into one of these four styles the first
ones Eureka breakthrough which you all
kind of know about this is when you
suddenly you know it it's concrete it's
certain and there's a great story about
the Blackhawk helicopters during the
Iraq war has lexan windshields which is
a hard plastic that scratches very
easily it's also used on NASCAR's so
these two NASCAR fans who were in the
National Reserve we're looking at all
these scratched up windshields that was
costing the army a fortune and they're
like well why don't we do at NASCAR does
they have these mylar tear ways that
they put on top of the windshields they
take all the scratches you pull them off
at the end of the race when shields find
they did that army save millions upon
millions of dollars and this was just
they had a moment it just made sense to
them they saw it that's Eureka then
there's metaphorical breakthroughs these
are less certain you Kanha you get an
image in your head you get a picture you
get an idea you have to interpret it to
get the aha moment and the most famous
one I apologize for the mispronunciation
olivia is by august kekulé a he's german
i apologize if i just mangled that who
was working on the shape of benzene in
the mid-1800s and he had a dream about a
snake eating its own tail and realized
oh benzene shaped as a ring it was in
the interpretation of the dream that he
was able to have his breakthrough so at
first you just get an image and you're
like okay great that was helpful you
have to work on it again we mean
executive network getting to work on it
to make sense of it the third one is
intuitive breakers intuitive
breakthroughs are also less certain you
you know a certain direction to go you
know a path you want to go down but
you're not sure where it's going to lead
and a great example of this is Chuck
Yeager first person to fly faster than
the speed of sound and before he did it
every pilot had died no one had gotten
faster than 0.85 Mach and the controls
would get difficult to use the
would start to wobble and the engineers
are starting to think it was impossible
and Jaeger had he had a moment he was
like I think the plane is going to get
easier to fly the closer I get to the
speed of sound now there was no reason
for him to know this the phd's they
didn't think this was true but sure
enough when he went up in the x1 the
closer he got to Mach the easier the
plane got to fly how did he know he had
an intuition there was something about
his deep mastery of flying that enabled
him to see what was going to be true and
he trusted it now the last one is called
paradigm breakthroughs we don't spend a
lot of time on this one because it's
rare this is world-changing relativity
style breakthroughs they tend to be to a
certain extent around the luck of timing
they tend to be based on a lot of
previous breakthroughs Einstein was
standing on the shoulders of a host of
breakthroughs all throughout the 19th
century and you can't really set out to
do it you're very probably end up down a
rabbit hole if they happen they happen
and that's wonderful and we will all be
grateful and you'll win a Nobel and
forever be a sconce in history but
chasing it is going to be kind of
difficult those are the four styles as I
said that we know so returning to the
shower for a moment why do we get these
good ideas in the shower
well the shower steps the perfect
conditions for mode switching you step
into the shower and your executive
network has just enough to do to keep it
occupied you're going to clean yourself
that's fine it creates a wonderful space
for your default Network to start coming
on start working and you bring your
neuroplasticity in which gives you the
muscle to start making different
associations so the shower becomes a
perfect place to bring all of these
tools together and you may have one of
the four styles of breakthroughs at any
point in their last thing
it's not going to be easy you are going
to face obstacles you're going to face
difficulties and you're going to have to
push through to talk about three of
these obstacles I'd love to introduce my
co-author and mother of dragons olivia
fox how many of you have being scared
watching a scary movie please raise your
hands
excellent now consciously you know that
was just movie right you know that those
actors up there are getting paid the
zillions of dollars in exchange to
looking like they're getting the head
chopped off yes that's consciously
however and in your body did you have
like your pulse racing and with your
palm sweating did you feel anything
physical when you were scared watching a
scary movie yes why with me please speak
up shout out so swearing is not very
good at knowing the difference between
imagination reality let me be a tiny bit
more specific and I'm going to try to
keep on time so we're going to skim over
a lot of stuff a lot of this science you
if you if you buy our book will be very
happy or published or even more so
please do but a lot of this stuff is
available for free on our website the
butterfly net so the butterfly net so
imagination reality effect a lot of the
same pathways in the brain and they have
a lot of the same effects in the body
now in normal life if you suddenly have
an experience of fear usually a it's not
really life-threatening and be it will
necessarily have consequences on
whatever breakthrough you're trying to
have however why is fear a problem for
breakthroughs breakthroughs thinking and
innovation well what happens when you're
scared what does your body do
Mindi system piloff life yes so tell me
about fight or flight your zebra running
away from a lion what does your body do
okay focus on what let's get specific
I'm amazed I really excited you guys to
know that seriously come on if you're
riding away from a line you're a zebra
and I said you know what stay human
that's fine you're running away from a
lion what does your body do the fight or
flight is designed to be an asset it's
supposed to help you what do you think
your body does so your muscles your
muscle reaction time increases what else
journalist a drill what's the adrenaline
do it's an excellent signal adrenaline
what does it lead to raises blood
pressure raises blood pressure whales
opens the thing the less horrible is
room yep so that the blood flows better
to your muscle that's great your heart
rate increases your vision gets more
acute so all these are critical things
to survive and what does it shut down
digestion
there you go fish I sound everything
that superfluous to run away from a lion
digestion immune system and indeed
superfluous abilities like cognitive
reasoning which means that just when you
need it most
if fear shows up on the way to
breakthrough it's usually fear failure
and we'll talk about that that's one
more primal parts of your brain hijack
control and shut down the very parts of
your brain you need one small thing to
know about fear and sorry I'm running
through my brain to see how much I can
cram into six minutes um you know what
we're going to move on to failure
there's a lot more on the website I
promise and in order to handle fear
there's a there's quite a few things you
can do there there's a mental tool to
there on some physical tools if you've
heard of the relaxation response it's a
it's a very good one to use
and if you have heard of that meditation
it's an excellent one to use too and but
I think that fear is covered enough
elsewhere that I'd really like to focus
on failure actually now I know that
especially at Stanford you're you're
told often that you should embrace
failure and failure is good and that's
great the problems that they don't tell
you how and what what is it that we when
we fear failure we fear of course the
consequences but we fear even more the
actual experience of failure itself and
fear plus failure can manifest in your
mind is a couple of things one the
impostor syndrome which you may have
heard of the impostor syndrome is this
unfortunate feeling that so many people
have that you're just waiting you don't
really know what you're doing and you're
just waiting for the other shoe to drop
for someone to find you out and exposed
as a fraud have any of you ever felt
this at Burt that's pretty confident
people okay and it turns out that since
the epochal syndrome was first starting
to be studied in the 70s and a vast
majority of population has felt this way
at some point or another but what's
fascinating is that the higher up the
level of education you go the worse it
gets
current theory is that the more you know
the more you're aware of how small does
sum total of knowledge the more you're
aware of how small your own knowledge is
in comparison but however that may be
the impostor syndrome is caused by a
self-image of yourself as not
fill-in-the-blank and for us with
breakthroughs it's usually a self-image
of yourself as not creative not a genius
not in the valley steve job so you can
you can rebuild your self-image and
you've got a couple of ways to do this
the easiest one is going to be to decide
which self-image you want in this case
let's say that you want to see yourself
as creative second gather past evidence
there's a couple of limitations in the
brain that are going to come in handy
it doesn't have a great sense of
imagination versus reality as we said it
also doesn't have a great sense of time
or scale have you ever heard of the
science of small wins so that is the
fact that okay have you ever had a day
where lots of little bad things happened
one after the other you get the feeling
that it's just one darn thing one after
the other and somehow that's harder to
live through than one big thing have you
ever had that experience that's because
our brain doesn't prioritize super well
it doesn't realize instinctively what
the the different importances are so
small acts of creativity stacked up if
there's lots of them it can seem the
same to your brain as one big creative
breakthrough and we're just trying to
change your self-image of how you see
yourself with regards to breakthroughs
another thing that you'll want to do if
you use the science of small wins a good
example if you see my eyes glancing up
by the way I'm looking at the clock so
another thing that you can do using the
science of small wins is start really
really small BJ Fogg who's here at
Stanford with the voices the persuasion
lab I think who has the method called
tiny habits which is absolutely
fantastic if you want to learn about
rituals and routines and habits backing
he's the guy to go to he recommends for
example that if you want to start
flossing sauce just one tooth that is
how easy you want to make it in the same
way if you want to change your
self-image and you want to have an image
of your brain as incredibly creative
start really really small you could for
example look around your office and
start making a backstories for the
object there like your photocopier name
is Phillips comes from Minnesota and
he's really big into ice hockey and you
start building things you start from the
really really really small and you start
stacking creative habits that way
fear failure and the last one of the
obstacle which is one of the biggest
ones you'll face and the one that we
don't speak of often enough increasingly
people do speak about how failure is
important and how you can go through it
etc but the way we handle uncertainty is
actually one of the biggest blockers on
the road to breakthroughs have you ever
had the feeling that you're when you're
waiting for a results and the feeling
that you rather even get bad news rather
than just being left in suspense
that's our inability to deal with
uncertainty why do we have this issue
with uncertainty it actually registers
in the brain like physical pain it's an
attention a gap that must be resolved
before you can move forward and just
like with fear and failure you can learn
how to handle uncertainty you can
practice uncertainty you can watch a
horror movie or a mystery movie and stop
before the end and then just fit and see
what's happening inside of you and learn
how to handle your feelings there's a
joke that meditators often say on
retreat which is um don't just do
something sit there often just sitting
there not running away not distracting
yourself the most courageous thing you
can do you can also use sports games you
can go to a game you can watch a game on
television where you don't know the
outcome which is one of the things we
love about games by the way and turn the
television off or leave the game and
then just handle the uncertainty that's
a good way to practice you can reduce
the uncertainty by learning how to think
like a poker player my favorite is Annie
Duke she has a great website with lots
and lots of tips on there and she has
books and courses when you think like
your poker player you're always thinking
in probability and that can help you
eight narrow down the range but also
realizing that there's never 100% or
never 0% when Annie first started dating
her boyfriend now fiance they're all
poker players her her brother they're
all champions and they've got the
bracelets etcetera
turns out that her family started making
bets on whether they get married and so
they actually named the option after the
couple facing probabilistically about
everything so talked about practicing
we've talked about reducing and the last
one is balancing uncertainty you'd be
surprised by how many very very creative
artists designers dancers have taken
their entire day and dropped it into
routine from morning to evening because
it's um we all have a certain threshold
above which our brain goes into this
fight-or-flight mode because there's too
much uncertainty so it's almost at least
you have a bucket a scale with a bucket
of certainty on one hand and uncertainty
on the other you need uncertainty to
have breakthroughs if you can't handle
uncertainty you only do things that are
guaranteed to work therefore that are
innovative that aren't new if you load
the certainty bucket with rituals
routines and habits as much as possible
then you can handle more uncertainty on
the other side does that make sense
okay last 30 seconds three best tools
that will work for all of these one is a
sense of purpose and when I say purpose
not necessarily higher or altruistic
purpose it's entirely Hitler had a
purpose it's entirely possible and very
frequent to have a purpose that is not
altruistic but a sense of purpose will
give you the sense that you're on a
mission my favorite example is Joan of
Arc this is a when she started out
twelve-year-old illiterate peasant girl
who and this believe me in medieval
France I'm French I would know this
would really be it was still is unheard
of that not only she made her way to the
French King not only convinced him to
send her at the head of the army but
then convinced the French army who
hadn't made a single attempt in nine
months to mount five attacks in a couple
of weeks
she changed the course of that war
imagine the difference if she'd seen
what she was doing as a project
instead it was her mission with her
purpose she turned that warrant a holy
crusade when you have a purpose it will
help you combat the fear and the sense
of failure and the uncertainty now if on
top of the purpose you add altruism then
that's as close to magic formula as
you'll ever get in breakthroughs and
Adam grant has a lot of wonderful
research on altruism which I highly
recommend that you look into I'm pretty
sure there's some of it on our website
along with a lot more brain research for
those of you who are hardcore geeks
altruism is measurably boost creativity
and it can also help you combat all of
those three
and lastly meditation you've heard of it
in all sorts of ways so you know it's
good for you think of it not like a
spiritual practice think of it as a
toolbox you wouldn't use a hammer and a
screwdriver for the same purpose or you
shouldn't use Mecca or the Posada and
meditation for the same purpose it's a
toolbox there's a lot of sites you can
learn about meditation I think that's it
thank you very much
[Applause]
opening the floor for questions so
there's a destructive as well as a
constructivist I love you say soccer
golly said the only difference between
myself in a madman is that I am not mad
you talk about trying to keep that
element of creativity at cold storage
for the Peace Project this is the idea
when I use the word discipline you're
you're kind of the did oh say so the
question was thank you the question was
how to balance the destructive elements
of the creative process and try and
steer them towards being more
constructive and when I spoke earlier
about discipline in this process that's
kind of what that is getting at it's
very romantic if you want to just
disappear into the default Network and
just imagine all these wonderful things
and and float out and not even think
about the consequences of them just feel
like this is what's important but the
reality is is that we have to go in and
have that creative space and then come
out and with a very clear eye very
logical rational I ask ourselves what am
i doing what is the purpose of what I'm
doing so it's the lack of discipline
around the creative process that leads
to the possibility of that
destructiveness so there's this
mythology we have up being creative or
you just you're crazy and wild and it
just pours out of you like a fountain it
isn't that amazing
and there are a lot of artists like that
and a lot of artists have been
incredibly self-destructive but if you
gain the inner discipline around the
creativity that's how you deal with that
situation at one point you mentioned
having an idea and all I would like to
work with it and my about it even if
it's not in the show of great view what
how would you describe
knowing when to bail on an idear like
you know like how do you know when to
not worth putting in that it's not a
good ideas on a search like you have any
tips on is it a peanut so the question
is if you have an idea you have a
breakthrough and then you're working on
it you're actually doing the discipline
thing and working on it how do you know
when to toss in the towel on the idea
it's an excellent question there is no
exact answer so and it depends on where
you get information some people will
feel it in their bodies some people will
just know like it's exhausting me to
keep working on this and at that point
I'm done other people will feel kind of
an intellectual wall so just realize I
just I'm just banging into a wall here
some people are going to feel literally
in your heart you're like my heart's no
longer in this I was very excited about
it and now I'm not so there's a certain
element of just listening to yourself
and asking yourself where you feel a bit
about how you feel about this but
another element is going back in so you
don't just mode switch once you don't go
into the default Network come out you
have an idea then you work on it it's a
dance that you're constantly moving back
and forth so if you find yourself
hitting the wall with an idea put it
aside leave it alone see if something
comes to you later
it might take a little while
screenwriters novelists painters
everyone has a story about taking a
piece of working on putting it in a
drawer putting it under a bed coming
back to it later when suddenly with
fresh eyes they see something so again
if you get into that executive network
mode and you're just trying to drill
down on something and it's not working
that might be time to pull back there's
also something about your question which
is can you please give me a deadline I
want to know for sure
and that's where a lot of us work on it
or driven by the executive network we
want a formula that I'll tell us well at
this point you know that's no longer
worth working on it and what we hate is
the uncertainty of not knowing when we
should bail that's exactly what you need
to learn how to handle because
unfortunately I know you're going to
hate this but there isn't an answer and
you're just going to give you all sorts
of intuitive we'd be very well up until
now of amazed eight minutes they can't
go too far bad either they give you all
sorts of
we did etcetera etc for people like me
driving batshit crazy sorry
unfortunately there is no hard enough
there on that one so on the other side
you have to come with anything as it
right through is genius and the next
imitate what was I thinking chemically
you did like Keith Richards and claims
of the idea how I get there now my
gloves are slams our ego thing I thought
it's going to buy houses with poor
choice how they sort of balancing things
like it's great in the way I think we
can buy it would it be fair to say that
what you're asking is how can we
evaluate what we've just come up with
whether it's what's in your net okay so
there are a number of tools and this is
where you come out of that creative
space and actually look at your idea in
the light of day and sometimes it's just
having that hard and fast look the next
morning sometimes it's having a crew
that you run things by that you trust
that you feel safe with and you go to
them you're like so I have this idea I
think it might be genius but it might be
crap and you know that they'll tell you
the truth another thing you can do is
just try it right I'm like all right I'm
just gonna I'm going to test this out
and see what happens sometimes what we
do is we get attached to our ideas and
we treat them like very delicate flowers
and we don't ever expose them to reality
and that's how we get caught in that
loop which also goes back to the earlier
question I like it just taking your idea
if you're if you're stuck on and just
put it out in the world and see what the
world does with it and that can
sometimes shift you and sometimes it's
hard you're like well I'm not good an
idea you know like oh and you kind of
want to slink away but yep that's sort
of a part of it
and also understandable cabinet
Peddapuram your venom it just amputated
by the Platinum you don't know how to
start shaping it are worth money anyway
we start start waiting honor
how do you how to get a year let us know
shaving your head large so the question
is what happens if you get a metaphor on
your head if you get a sort of
half-formed idea in your head and you
can't it that's all it is it's half
belong metaphor how do you actually work
with that first of all if you don't get
metaphors that's okay
I say metaphor race true is really what
you have to realize is that of all the
cells of breakthroughs and remember
before that we categorize it was just
for ease of writing but there's no one
style of breaker that's better than
another she gets metaphorical
breakthroughs I tend to get Eureka
you've never had a Eureka breaks or have
you no no he's terrible um and
occasionally I'll get intuitive just
because I've been in this work so long
do you ever get intuitive I do really
anyway so just realizing that all
breakthrough Styles are equally worthy
okay take a metaphor okay so if you have
this metaphor and you can't make heads
or tails of it there's a couple of
things you can do one again share it
with people see what they say it's not
that they're necessarily going to have
the answer but whatever they give you
will kind of shift you're stuck place
another thing you can do is look at the
metaphor and ask yourself where's this
coming from
is it something from my childhood is it
something I read recently what's the
meaning of this read about it look into
it research it it might pop you into
understanding what is it that was shown
to you and another possibility is take
the metaphor you with your executive
network and focus your default network
on it go back in see what happens if you
just turn on the metaphor if so if
something popped back out at you those
are the three main ways to try and
engage it and sometimes to go to the
earlier point just not really an idea
which happens a lot you want more
where did dreams come into play oh boy
go first so the question is where do
dreams come into play with this and the
safe answer is it depends on who you ask
some people will tell you dreams are
just a random assortment of things going
on as your brain
clears itself out from day's occurrences
other people will tell you dreams are
your unconscious your unconscious way of
talking to yourself of giving you
answers there are so many stories of
people having breakthroughs coming in
dreams that for me it's hard to ignore I
personally don't know what the mechanism
is but the sheer number of people that
have woken up and been like oh that's my
answer from Einstein to Mendeleev to
Pascal it it just goes on and on and on
so from my point of view dreams are a
time when the default network is very
very active and it's that it's a kind of
a metaphorical way of the default
Network showing you a connection and
just also to say that when we do talk
about the hypnagogic and hypnopompic
states liminal space between falling
asleep and waking up in which so many
people seem to have great ideas it's ok
if you don't I have never in my life
woken up with a good idea I don't do
naps well so apparently for a lot of
people taking a nap can feel that you
feel refreshed I wake up I'm like a
zombie I crave marshmallows so I think
that what we'd really want to leave you
with is own learn to work with your
Styles your strengths you'll have your
own signature breakthrough styles you'll
have your own techniques that work for
you and there's no one magic formula I'd
love it if there if there were he
wouldn't but work with with what works
for you and I think that we're good yep
all right thank you
[Applause]
you